Rachele follows me on Twitter at Dave
Ramsey in about 800,000 everyday what's
the craziest thing that's happened to
you on the air you get some crazy calls
sometimes yeah we've had some lanky ones
over the years I you know there's
several of them they come to mind it's
just funny I mean when you look back on
the worst ones are the mistakes that I
make I have this penchant for using the
exact wrong description a metaphor on
something like the guy that called in
that had lost his leg and I said well
you got to get back up on your feet you
know I mean I do stuff like that that's
awful
and you know or a lady whose husband was
killed on a bicycle and you know five
minutes down in the conversation I'm
talking to this widow and I'm not you
know it you know it's just like learn to
ride a bike you got to get back on and
ride again I actually said that to that
woman and I made no connection
apparently she didn't either because she
didn't like fall on the floor and go
that's the dumbest human on the planet
that I'm talking to but I have done
stuff like that I've said that my team
has collected those over the years and
so that's when I'm screwing up is
crazier than the caller's I mean it's
it's funny stupid it really is and I've
done a bunch of those we did have one
guy called in and was like I died my
wife won't have sex with me if I don't
make at least six hundred thousand or
six hundred dollars a month what do you
think and I said well I think you should
get to her he start he started cussing
and screaming and dropping f-bombs so we
had that did the dump button it didn't
make the air y'all never heard that part
because we're not allowed to let it on
FCC will find us a Janet Jackson fine if
we do that so we're not allowed to put
stuff like on there we don't put it on
anyway but it was pretty funny
yeah we've got a few of those over the
years and you know the the more
entertaining ones are always usually
when somebody's mad you know but we
would get a lot of that it's not you
know it's hard to make somebody mad when
you get them out of debt you know it's
usually some whole life agent or
something that's mad we get some of
those and while those guys are called in
a couple of times he was a character for
a few years back and you just enjoyed
getting his butt whipped so I obliged a
couple times
on the air that was fun um I don't know
I mean we do it's just its life and it's
real people happening right here on the
air and you can't make this stuff up if
you were sitting down to write out a
script you can't make up some of the
stuff people say on the show and they
say it in front of 13 million of you you
know I'm amazed at some of the things
they will say they have done and you
know I did have one lady I had forgotten
that until just not just flash there in
my head um she was having an affair on
her husband and one of me to explain to
her how she could best walk through this
affair and get a divorce and get her
husbands I end up with most of his
wealth she actually called anyone me to
connive against the guy that she's
cheating on on the air I mean I'm a
woman you do you have any idea who you
call they you're really stupid aren't
you that's what's going through my head
and finally I'm talking to her and it
finally just kind of made me mad huh
pretty much just dumped her and took off
but I probably should have kept her on
the air mess with her for the
entertainment value on radio but I mean
it's just her moral compass was so
backward and screwed up and broken that
you know you couldn't there was no
negotiating with her so you might as
well you know turn into great radio I
guess but that's the kind of stuff
that's weird where people are just so
far out there but truthfully the
craziest funniest things are the
mistakes I've made
they definitely when I have has only
been think in 25 years I think I've
completely lost my composure laughing so
hard that I couldn't breathe like a 13
year old girl in the lunchroom you know
and I couldn't recover and they had to
take us to break because I just lost it
on this you know stupid stuff somebody
said or something funny they said or
something that happened in the studio
when I say something they're in the
studio laughing and I'm supposed to keep
a straight face then right because
they're laughing at me when I've made a
mistake and I got to just keep going
because something has come out of my
mouth that shouldn't have and James and
Kelly are no help at all they're causing
all kinds of problems with laughing in
it because if they start laughing then I
start laughing and then you know then
the whole thing's just messed up you
can't play it off then right
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]